it's a dramatic scene
wow that is
psycho
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by kevin bacon he's a
gold globe award-winning actor with
countless timeless titles over the
course of his 40-plus year-long
hollywood career including apollo 13 a
few good men footloose mystic river and
many more these days though you can
catch them starring in the acclaimed
crime drama city on a hill which begins
its third season on showtime sunday july
10th kevin bacon welcome to the show
thanks for having me how are you around
hot sauce i know that you like to hit
your morning mango with a little bit of
chili powder yeah i like hot sauce i
don't know there's this thing what they
say if you if you use it too much then
your taste buds get burned out and then
you need to use more
it's a it's a gateway drug or something
i don't know i i
but i like it i'm living proof you know
what the taste buds they don't burn away
i can still taste as good as that okay
good i'm glad nine years ago so we can
just dive in here good i'm glad to hear
at the handle
[Music]
hmm
good
you got me a little bit of
a little lime in there maybe
yeah
i like it
so in the gritty boston-based crime
drama city on a hill you play the often
cd always swaggering fbi agent jackie
rohr and i've heard you describe the
show as being like shakespeare with a
lot of [ __ ] can you unpackage that i
love it as a tagline well you know when
i first read the script um
what i really found interesting about
the character was was obviously a man of
the street at the same time he's like
incredibly well-read and incredibly
verbose
you know sometimes i do parts where
uh i i like to
kind of lean into saying a lot with a
very little and then every once in a
while something comes along where the
guy can't just can't shut the [ __ ] up
and and it's just really fun to just
kind of lean into that and they always
write me good stuff to say
[Music]
mm-hmm
yup
delicious
and your wings are very good too i might
add them thank you thank you so much
thank you dom quick shot over there
so i want to stay on the topic of
television because it marks a distinct
shift for you saying in a 2017 interview
with the guardian before my managers
knew never to mention a tv series
because they knew how furious that would
make me what do you see as the forces at
play that have driven so many actors
away from film and towards television
over the last decade or so
um
well i think what happened was
writers
on films a lot of people
aren't really aware of this
are
strangely kind of the low men on the
totem pole they're low people on the
totem pole
um
on a on a film set on a movie set once
the writer has delivered the script
the director and the actors and the
producers just kind of traditionally
have pushed them aside and said well now
this is our movie and we're going to um
make it ours you know
even in the editing process scenes that
were incredibly important to a writer
get lifted and taken out
and at one point i think they all went
you know what
[ __ ] that
you know i'm gonna go
where i can be
the show runner
so when the great writers
started to see that that was an
opportunity they went to television and
then that sort of
golden age of sopranos and six feet
under the wire and all these tv shows
that i was sitting home and watching and
just looking at and going [ __ ] i want to
do that
and then it's interesting to me that in
the beginning of your career you know
box office was everything and then that
gives way to blockbuster and rentals
which gives way to dvds which gives way
to streaming and then now coming out of
this pandemic it's kind of these like
dual theatrical releases along with
on-demand what do you see as like the
biggest existential threat to the
movie-making industry having lived
through so many tectonic shifts in your
career well you know you you make a good
point
i lift through so many shifts and i
never really thought they were shifts
people would say hey you know the movie
business has changed the way you know
when i first started out
we didn't even have cameras everything
was live um you know
we live in a world of increasingly haves
and have-nots and that seems to have
reflected its way into the movie
business where
you can you put 200 million dollar
movies in in the theaters
but the movies that i'm going to be in
you know are going to have a harder time
finding a theatrical kind of release
but i'm gonna hold on to the dream
that
people will never stop wanting to you
know buy some shitty popcorn and and sit
there and and uh
and experience that with strangers
[Music]
okay
oaxacan
that's gotten spicy
[Music]
that's only the third one [ __ ]
okay yeah that's getting there hey so
do you put this this you put it on
before the chicken wings are cooked or
afterwards this is too technical no no
no i i love to love getting into the
mechanics of it all so um it's after so
the wings come in
bare okay naked however you want to put
it and then a little double bowl toss
action okay with the sauces so you get
that full coverage so you can't escape
kevin you can't escape that's good wow
all right
is it true that while preparing for your
role in footloose that you actually
attended a real life actual high school
as a transfer student under the assumed
identity run mccormick yeah this is the
world's dumbest ride-along
you know i mean
i wanted to see what the experience
would be of an urban kid as a kid wasn't
footloose moving into a rural
environment very very different
culturally
it was so much like the movie i can't
tell you it was like
some of the bad some of the badass kids
were like hey who you who are you punk
yum you know they were like whatever and
you know fronting with me in the
bathroom and stuff and then there was
like this big
kind of dude corn-fed dude who was you
know took me under his wings like hey
y'all back off i got it i got it he's
okay um and the girls when i walked down
the hall were giggling and like
i had thought if the character walked
into the school on the first day that he
would be you know come on bring it and
it was the complete opposite when i
walked into that school i was like oh
[ __ ]
so it actually did inform
the
in in in in a in a way that was pretty
specific you know um
and then when this crew showed up i was
like thank god you guys are here
let's go to the bar air lift me out of
here let me out of here yeah
hmm
got good hot sauces here man
so far i guess right yeah
has anyone ever tried to switch them i
don't know why you'd want to do that so
there's a couple times where it's almost
like accidentally happened oh you know
like tom holland comes in like hi nice
to meet you and then goes and reaches
for like number 10 right away i've heard
that about him yeah you know dom has to
fly in here and fall in the grenade and
then we had one guest eddie wong way way
back in the day that actually did it in
reverse seemingly on purpose would not
recommend after seeing the way that that
played out in real time
so i know that you left home at age 17
with broadway dreams starting out at the
legendary circle in the square theater
where the likes of pacino hoffman and
street have gone through
can you recall an instance ever a time
in which your formal acting training
brushed up awkwardly with the realities
of being on a hollywood set
well
that's a really interesting question um
when i did the movie diner i learned a
great lesson from barry levinson
being young and also really coming from
the stage
i tended to be
kind of bigger you know and tended to
want to
put it out into the back row whatever it
was that i i was feeling
and he was like you know don't don't
play it someone yeah you know you can
just uh you know you know the lesson
it's you know and and so
i did less and i did less and he would
have me do less again
and
that was a great sort of lesson to me um
also you can't necessarily judge a part
based on the amount of lines that you
have
if you
listen to people and you have a good
sense of
who your
guy is
you can make an impact you can make your
your presence known without just a bunch
of this
[Music]
hmm
seven people yeah
um
yeah i see why
that's a little guy on a horse looking
like he's about to smack you in the head
okay
what to you is the most interesting or
fascinating thing about working on the
simulators that the us space and rocket
center in the lead up to apollo 13.
that was an incredible experience i mean
we were doing touch and goes in
airplanes i mean all this kind of thing
this is one of the great things about
this gig that i have i mean the
experiences that i have and the things
that i get to be able to do or just i i
never take them for granted i really
don't
in that case
there was a plane called the kc-135
they fly out over the gulf of mexico you
climb straight up and then you dive and
these are called parabolas for 24
seconds i think it is you float i did it
i got through it
i was like great we all jumped off the
plane we kissed the tarmac it was
terrifying
um
but kind of cool oh had that experience
so ron
has a conversation a conversation with
steven spielberg
and spielberg says you know
why don't you shoot some of the movie up
in that plane
and you have to keep in mind that at
this point making people float was a
really hard thing to accomplish uh in
terms of special effects
and you know uh ryan comes back guys
guys guys guys got a great idea
it's talking to stephen what we're gonna
do i was like are you [ __ ] kidding me
we're gonna be up in this thing
for like weeks now
myself tom and bill at ron we did this
like 600 times wow but what was really
cool was that
not
all three of us would be on in the scene
at once maybe it was just me or maybe it
was just tom or bill or whatever
and then the whole rest of the plane was
like a big uh
uh padded cell
and so we would just
have fun
just play football fly around fly like
literally
you could
you could start at this wall and push
off picture just flying all the way to
this wall i mean just like this you know
you can see there's goofy uh footage of
it so
again
what an experience
[Music]
going in
so interesting
almost forget how it
kind of raises your uh your uh heart
rate right yeah yeah it's a little
trippy too like sometimes trying to
actually get like kind of like a head
high off yeah a little bit yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
wow man
i love you man
i love you right
so besides movies i know that music is a
major passion of yours starting a band
with your brother michael 25 years ago
the bacon brothers and releasing close
to a dozen studio albums and the time
since as someone with a with a foot in
both worlds is there a movie a project
of yours that you think has the best or
most underrated original soundtrack
ah of mine
probably i i it's been a while since
i've gone back and listened to it but
probably telling lies in america and of
course i i think of that because i wrote
a couple songs for it but that's not
that's not really the reason i wrote i
wrote a song called medium rare that
they actually sang in the movie and it
was cool to try to write in a specific
kind of style of an error and stuff like
that you know what else has probably i'm
guessing although i don't honestly go
back and look at the movies but i'm
guessing that has a good soundtrack
would be uh she's having a baby
because john hughes was a huge huge
people forget he was a huge music fan it
was also really super super influential
in things that were gonna you know be on
the radio and you know really i'm sure
there's a lot of cool music in that
tissue time tissue time
tissue time are you ready to move on to
just an anticipation my nose started to
run yeah this is the uh hollow key here
okay in the seventh spot
[Music]
that doesn't even
[Music]
what's amazing is that they haven't even
they haven't
highlighted all of those peppers
that they've only highlighted
four out of five i think that's uh false
advertisement because that shit's hot
very hot yeah very hot one seven spot
awesome
i'm really enjoying this you're having a
good time
i am
i am
did you have a biggest customer pet
peeve when you were going by vooner and
waiting tables at the uh
dlc cafe
my biggest customer pet peeve man your
research is deep bro
lunar
that is
i got some friends that are gonna [ __ ]
when they hear that that you
figured that out
um
my biggest pet peeve
would be um
splitting dishes
it was an interesting restaurant that i
worked at it's on 72nd street up here
because service was not really the deal
i mean i was i was by far
the most uh agreeable person
that worked there the bartenders the
waitresses it was not none of this what
can i get you sir
no it was nothing like that
uh so
you know it was it was not you know uh
lesarc
[Music]
the bomb
sorry about that
okay
oh my god
i'm embarrassed to show you how small a
bite i took with this to move it
well all you need is a small bite
wow that's hot
wow
it's insane it's beyond insane beyond
insanity
you'd have to put it on with like a
pin
wow
oh my gosh that's hot very hot very hot
wow
awesome good delicious
love it
besides the time that you did your
screen test with 104 degree fever for
diner what immediately comes to mind
when you think of harrowing audition
experiences
um
so
when i wasn't at the tappet keg
i would sometimes go to studio 54.
i would go alone because i love to dance
i learned pretty quickly that it wasn't
a place to pick up girls because i
didn't have enough money or enough coke
and
there's a guy named mark who had blonde
here
was mark and steve
rubell and and
he was in turn uh in charge of picking
who was going to be able to come through
the red road oh he was like yeah in
charge of the velvet over there right he
was the guy
and everyone's screaming mark mark two
mark two
mark three mark and and
it was complete insanity
and i noticed him going like this
and looking over and then going
and i thought to myself
he's looking at their shoes
and so i started to look at the shoes
that people would wear
and then i went out and got a pair of
those shoes
and i got it so then the the 70s end and
they decided to do a show called got to
go disco which is a broadway show
there was a song called i love the
nightlife
i love the nightlife i like the boogie
on the
so i come in
uh with the sheet music and i handed the
piano player he starts to play it
it never occurred to me that the sheet
music might not be in the key
of the record it was a disaster it was
way out of my range and the weirdest
thing was i'd never had i don't ever had
a
musical audition before
there's a room full of probably
i don't know 20 people 30 people all
investors and and sitting right in the
middle was this guy mark and all i could
think was mark one
mark one
uh he was one of the producers
and uh
to say that i didn't get that part would
be the understatement i just completely
[ __ ] the bed
well it sounded good when you just sang
it just now and then you did it under
the pressure of eight hot sauces yeah so
i don't think these hot sauces are
really great for the old vocal cords
so impressive under the circumstances
are you ready to move on here to number
nine interesting title for number nine
the psycho sauce yeah mm-hmm
starting to see why you might put that
at the end there
[Music]
oh man
wow
okay
what does that mean 15 out of 10
right it doesn't make any sense
that doesn't make any sense at all you
know like they're coming but i mean it
does make sense right now this is like
when my mouth is going you're right
[ __ ] that's 15 out of 10.
oh my god
wow that is
psycho
how would you describe your ideal day at
macedonia state park hot ones creator
chris schoenberger he takes his dog
ruggles running there every single day
well my favorite time to go to macedonia
state park is after a big snow
there's a two mile
uh gradual uphill
trail
for a cross-country skiing
and it's it's perfect because you're
you're going uphill on the way
and then you
get nice and warm and then you just kind
of it's it's a little easier on that
it's very hard to answer these questions
[Music]
you're kidding you want me to put oh man
you don't have to if you don't want to
listen you're too nice good you need to
have more rules i mean you need to ah
be careful be careful
all right
do you find that
[Music]
men and women react differently of
course they react differently but isn't
is
is there a sort of a an element that
comes up with guys are like oh no it's
like a
we've never had a woman tap out on the
show ever that's amazing
[Music]
[Music]
i know it's funny how
i know
oh [ __ ] me
it's funny how it
just kind of builds you know yeah
there's a cumulative effect i think of
like putting all these 10 and layering
them on top but the good news is you're
all done with the wings we've taken a
journey through your acting career and
it's clear that you're someone who loves
movies ever since you snuck into that
dollar theater when you were 12 years
old to see midnight cowboy on the topic
of the movies that shaped you what makes
spinal tap a perfect film oh it's got
rock and roll it's got transformational
performances from people who don't look
or act anything like the characters that
they played
[Music]
it's got
humor
and then a unexpected
uh
touch of pathos
and it goes up to 11.
some would say maybe even goes up to 15.
some would say and look at you kevin
bacon taking on the wings of death
living to tell the tale and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
i'm gonna
[Laughter]
i'm gonna try to get out of this and
walk downstairs and go home
i don't know maybe take a nap
got city on the hill coming out i got
some new bacon brothers music coming out
wow it's hard to do under these
circumstances the walls are closing
[Applause]
thank you thank you everybody good job
good job that's the hot ones experience
that was amazing
i honestly i don't know where you get
these uh questions from but they are
well i know because i've seen the show
that they are very
surprising and incredibly well
researched oh thank you so much yeah i
mean it's it's nice to it's not just the
wings it's also nice to have a
you know have some [ __ ] to talk about
that's not
you know the usual
oh my god
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement we've read the
comments we've seen the emails and after
six years more than 250 episodes we can
now bring you the full hot ones
experience in one convenient package i'm
proud to introduce you to hot ones
boneless chicken bites available
exclusively at walmart and walmart.com
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ave apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home
hot ones boneless chicken bites it's a
party in a bag and everyone's invited
[Music]